someone hundreds of miles from the
nearest city deep in the forests of New
Hampshire sits a grand old hotel it was
here 70 years ago that America was
crowned the world's economic superpower
it was here in these halls and corridors
the world changed forever now it is on
the brink of changing again I think this
is a decisive election for the United
States and it will matter importantly
for the world economy in the global
financial system China has taken us over
nothing's american-made anymore whatever
we asked it in the United States about
brexit will be nothing compared to what
new breaths will asked about if we elect
Trump that's what all presidents say
they don't to make America great 51 I
still haven't seen it yet it's very
clear that America's role as the
dominant force in the global economy is
coming to an end we're in the Great Hall
of the Omni Mount Washington resort in
Bretton Woods New Hampshire this was the
last of the Grand Hotel's to be built
probably one of the more paramount times
in our history was obviously the
monetary conference of 1944 we discussed
our plans for the stabilization of world
currency this is the place where where
those 44 nations came to kind of guide
us out of World War two you can
literally say that you know establishing
the price of gold at $35 an ounce and
really making the dollar the dominant
currency that would back that gold up
happen right here at this location
the united states since world war ii has
played the role of global architect of
major institutions and all of the global
organizations the IMF the World Bank the
United Nations the World Trade
Organization the Bretton Woods Accord
those all sound very global they are
American institutions Americans values
American allies American standards
American Capital American priorities
American industry to save production
costs so what happened what happened to
the American Dream which brought decades
of prosperity growth innovation new
products new services free trade free
flows of capital not just for America of
the entire world when did all this turn
into a nightmare at least part of the
answer is what happened to America's
Rust Belt
well Wall Street boomed the factories
here are abandoned empty victims of
cheap competition from Mexico and China
welcome to this city of Reading
Pennsylvania back in 2010 we were
considered the poorest of the nation of
the city of its size we've had people
that have come through our system
because the tannery they worked in a
tannery the tannery left and went to
Mexico they're going overseas so we see
a lot of good you know hard-working
people frustrated coming into homeless
services saying I never thought this
would be me
we thought we could retire here we
thought this we could raise our family
this way and it just was pulled out from
underneath one time we were known as the
outlet capital of the country I think
back when this was booming and you know
you couldn't find a parking space here
people came from all over the country it
was really vibrant and now look at it so
there's a lot of hopelessness and
desolation I mean imagine getting up in
the morning and this is what you see
this doesn't give you hope you know
they're looking at this type of thing in
it you know sort of feel like you know
I've been kind of forgotten we've been
forgotten here
hey user hope for reading the motto of
this homeless shelter without a job you
cannot get anywhere and the way the
economy is now you see how the economy
is it's so many closed buildings here a
lot of bounded houses a lot of banned in
stores down on Penn Street I mean
nobody's buying that's what all
presidents say they don't I mean you
know America great I'm 51 I still
haven't seen it yet there's always the
problems I think when I was a kid it was
a prosperous place no not now that I'm
growing up and I'm saying when my dad
went through it's hard it's not a
prosperous space because they put you to
struggle out there I think the
frustration is the Main Street they've
lost the confidence in the Republican
and Democrat one of the largest rallies
I've seen here in a while was the Bernie
Sanders rally they they want something
different they're saying this isn't
working
Bernie Sanders particularly pulled
Hillary Clinton very very far towards a
less trade friendly policy I think in
the Republican Party which is completely
roiled and in chaos to some extent I'm
not sure Trump's positions
representative the fact that it's
working that he has so much over the
vote that he was able to win the
Republican nomination may influence
other candidates running for the House
of Representatives for the Senate I'm
certainly very concerned about what this
shows for the future in the United
States at least the next five years of a
country retrenching less confident about
its role in the world less confident
about trade safety beam guard rail is
cold form from strip steel but try to
put yourself in the position of the
people who live here in the Rust Belt
who worked for industrial giants like
Bethlehem Steel who helped build the
skyscrapers and railroads while the rest
of America powered on this place feels
like it was left behind
after a hundred and forty years of
continuous hot metal production the
furnaces are cold and silent this
Christmas the passing of an era that has
left Bethlehem with little to celebrate
in this season of goodwill given that
many of the jobs here fell victim
effectively to cheap imports from
overseas that's no surprise that both of
the candidates have disavowed free trade
whether that's TPP TTIP even existing
girls like NAFTA why stay open
when effectively that means places like
this get close he worked at the bottom
of SM steel and you stayed long enough
you worked your way up the ladder you
had wonderful benefits you had perks you
had a lot of things that in today's
world are not seen in corporate America
the Free Trade Act was kind of like
thrown at us for stannis your blue
collar guy you better be a serious one
here this arrived to bring jobs back to
our country you know should be a
priority
we have young children graduating
college and having no job market
China's taking us over you know it's
like when nothing's American made and we
have clothing nothing's american-made
America needs to support America in any
way maybe it's somewhere but America is
supporting wherever they can get a
cheaper there is another current and
there is a sentiment in the population
and it's not only in in the u.s. it's in
other countries as well which try to
reject the system reject the system that
is not providing them the level of
comfort and security that they would
expect from that that message is coming
out quite loud and clear now the
response that has been found to those
sentiments has been what take care of
that don't worry vote for me will take
care of that because we will stop
imports from country ABCD etc etc in
terms of actual policies that will be
the wrong policy it starts with the
wrong diagnosis if you diagnose the
problem as a trade problem you begin
with the wrong diagnosis and then you
prescribe the wrong medicine the World
Trade Organization which sits here on
the banks of Lake Geneva is in many
senses the home of globalization these
men and women spend their days
discussing trade barriers trying to
cooperate this is America's post-war
legacy what's unique about this place is
that every nation from Afghanistan to
Zimbabwe gets a say it's all done
through consensus and the question is
what kind of a world does the next u.s.
president want us to live in is it one
where things are agreed this way or is
it going to be every country for itself
if the country like the United States
disconnects from the global economy it's
a disaster it's a disaster it's a
catastrophe for the economy so that is
not going to happen any of those
policies that are being proposed if
implemented actually you're out of power
in four years as it happens this very
building was originally
as the headquarters of the League of
Nations the precursor to the UN it fell
apart because the u.s. refused to become
a member an important lesson I went to
dozens if not hundreds of international
meetings and the only ones that worked
were the ones that followed us
leadership if the u.s. does not give
leadership whether it's to the g7 or the
g20 the umbrella for happens mr. Trump
were to be elected we really have no
idea what he would do but it clearly is
unlikely to be a cooperative movement in
the world economy I think there's a lot
of uncertainty as to what the US will do
and it matters at this juncture good use
of Washington they believe that working
men were good men and treated them with
dignity what Trump is president I'm
afraid that we will see a world that is
not au s open that is hot as it has been
and my change development in the world
and I think that would be to go in the
wrong direction but of course also
Hillary Clinton has been skeptical to
some of the trade agreements so I hope
that if she becomes president we will
still see a development towards a more
open and globalized economy I do think
there is a danger that the that the next
administration whatever its identity
will draw back from globalization and if
that danger eventuates we're going to
have to blame ourselves for not having
done more to deal with the problem of
secular stagnation and not having done
more to deal with the problem of
inequality
it is autumn in America but what comes
next an economic freeze or the green
shoots of recovery the reality is the US
has always had a bit of an ambivalent
actually towards its role as leader of
the free world
they've always been disillusioned about
the state of the economy and about the
way that money's being shared between
people but throughout the years this
country is shown a remarkable attitude
at reinventing itself of boosting growth
and coming back to the brink as the
great British economist John Maynard
Keynes said at a conference here at
Bretton Woods in 1944 how much better
that our projects should begin in
disillusion than that they should end in
it
you